okay so um what inspired you to play
football in the first place
um
i don't really remember because i
started so young
i didn't really have a moment of
watching something and thinking
wow like that's that's what i want to do
i want to play football i think it was
just always just part of my family and
then
as i got older my brother was playing
so i wanted to be better than him
so i think that was kind of what kept me
going a lot and now he doesn't play
anymore so i'm like okay cool um but
yeah i think it was just my family just
football crazy absolute football crazy
uh what would you say that's been like
the highlight of your career so far
it's good because i've got a few but
i've also got some good ones that have a
bad ending so it's like
the world cup obviously winning a bronze
medal in the world cup was amazing but
when you look at the way that kind of we
didn't make it to the final that was
quite tough um but yeah winning the
bronze medal making my england debut and
scoring was pretty cool
and then obviously playing in the
champions league final was amazing but
obviously not the best ending over so
i think it takes a long time for you to
kind of
get over the bad feeling and then
realize kind of what the accomplishment
is getting to their moments so yeah i'd
probably say them three are probably up
there as my top favorites
what is it like going to st george's
park
it's pretty cool you know i remember the
first time i went there and i was a bit
like in or a little bit you know you're
looking around oh my god this is just
amazing you've got massive pictures up
on the wall and you get to sign you know
the wall when they were doing the
signatures and they're like go on then
sign it i was like oh okay like buzzing
about it um but yeah it's cool you know
it's amazing facilities amazing place to
go and when you go there you really kind
of feel that you're part of england and
you're part of like representing your
country so yeah it's pretty cool have
you been yeah yeah it's pretty sick yeah
i guess like football means like
different things to each person like
some people just find it comforting some
people play professionally like yourself
what does football mean to you
i think if you were to ask me this
question like two years ago i'd probably
say that it was like my whole life
obviously since then a lot of things
have happened
and i had to kind of learn
to find joy outside of football i think
football was such a big part of my mood
how i was like obviously i was speaking
earlier and you know i hate losing i
still have that now like probably you
guys when you play you hate losing but
literally like it would drain me for
days you know if we lost a game or
whatever and i think as i kind of took a
step back obviously when i had my
illness i had to really think about how
i was going to find joy when i couldn't
do something that i love to do
so obviously football is a massive part
of my life and it's something that i
love doing and i love to be a part of a
team and do everything like that so yeah
i mean it still is my life but i have
other
ways of finding that happiness when
maybe things aren't going particularly
well on the pitch
so during your recovery that was that
one thing that you learned about
yourself
um that's a really good question
[Laughter]
i think just not to take
things too seriously
like i said before like when i lost a
game like i don't think anyone could
talk to me for days you know i was just
miserable like
people would ask me how was the game
like no don't talk to me about it like i
don't want to know where it's like i
think
when you kind of have that step away and
you kind of value other things you value
life
you know for me football was a part of
my life but it doesn't define who i am
so i think that was a really big thing
that i learned during that recovery and
also kind of changing my mindset from
losing how do i change my mindset from
thinking we lost to learning
learning how to get better learning what
went wrong
so i think that was one thing that i
looked at as well more the psychology
side of it
do you feel like the woman's game is
improving
i think so i think on and off the pitch
i think the more opportunities that
we're giving
girls away from a professional
environment is encouraging them to want
to be professional
i think when i was growing up you know
there wasn't many options for me to play
of course you know you had the football
teams i was probably playing in a boys
team for a long time whereas now you see
girls being able to play in a girls only
team and you know creating more bonds in
that kind of way um so yeah i think as
there's more opportunities you've got
more girls coming through not just
players but coaches as well people who
can coach girls at a high standard
and then obviously on the pitch in terms
of professionally more professional
teams you know the game's obviously now
being played on sky sports and bbc
um so yeah i think each year it's
building and i still think there's a way
to go but i think we're definitely going
in the right direction
when you signed for chelsea did you have
to perform an initiation
luckily for me back then we weren't
doing it
so i was quite happy about that so i'm
not singing anything for you now
but if you had to what song would you
have picked oh good question i'd
probably go like an old song just
because then you can get people going
like dance with somebody whitney houston
or something like that you know when you
can kind of get the crowd going like
you're not just singing a ballad you
know i think we had
a crystal done she sung um refugees um
and she was just pure ballad obviously
she could sing a little bit so it was
all right whereas i've absolutely no
chance so i'd probably have to get the
crowd going and singing with me but
yeah luckily enough for me we weren't
doing it then i think it was a few years
later we started to do them so
i'm quite happy about that
what would yours be
um you're gonna say something like drake
or
no something whitney houston or anything
now it's like
no i'd probably be like a dave song or
something oh okay
[Music]
yours
chris brown chris brown nice
okay you know what oh you said drake i
was gonna say drake
if you're gonna say drake it's cool i'm
just saying when i was growing up it was
all you know
chris brown a bit of whitney so yeah
um who's got the most energy in the
lioness team
lionesses are jill scott is it yeah
without a shadow of a doubt that girl is
just constant constant constant like
when we were in the um in japan recently
like it was really strict in terms of
covid so you could only kind of like
socialize with your roommate
and like i can imagine that killed jill
you know because she's such a social
butterfly like she wants to know what
everyone's doing like she can't just
like sit in one place like she has to be
going here there and everywhere so
definitely jill for sure like in the
changing room she's up dancing to every
song and everything yeah
that was like who i thought it would be
who did you think it was gonna be
fair rage and millie have a lot of
energy
but jill was just always
yeah always always wow
from the socials i thought you would say
like
maybe leah or nikita yeah keats is a bit
yeah keith's got a good energy um but
yeah jill is more the one that kind of
like is going around everyone like
chatting away like she could literally
chat to a goal post you know i mean like
and get a conversation out of it like
[Music]
all right so
if football wasn't your career
where do you think you would be right
now
i used to do um judo
growing up um
and yeah i was pretty good
my
teacher master whatever they were back
then i don't even remember that it's
been that long um
he wanted me to pick judo because i had
to pick between the two obviously to
decide if i was going to go more serious
with football or judo and he really
wanted me to pick judo so yeah i'd
probably be do something like that but i
know i'd be in sport
i really wanted to do physiotherapy and
stuff like that so i'd definitely be in
sport for sure
if you were to like give your younger
self one piece of advice know what you
know now what would what would it be
get ready
i think
get ready for the roller coaster get
ready for the emotions you know for me
like i said football is
the biggest part of my life but also you
know it also brings me the lowest parts
of my life
losing big games
injuries illness you know there's so
many things that play a massive part in
your emotions so i think for me it would
be
get ready for the roller coaster but in
the end it will be worth it
um
and that's i think that's in life as
well i mean i think you know there's so
many ups and downs so yeah i think it's
just be ready for the life that it's
going to teach you a lot of lessons
so um what advice do you have for like
younger girls who are trying to become a
professional
take every opportunity that you can
i think for females growing up you know
even now still there's probably not as
many
opportunities as i would like there to
be
for young girls so if you get an
opportunity to do it just take it you
know take it and just go and enjoy it i
think you always
do things better when you enjoy things
and when you
are in a company of good people
so yeah i think it would probably be
yeah just take the opportunities and
enjoy them
what's your favorite pair of trainers
nice i'm a bit of an air force girl to
be fur yeah
um
yeah just you know just look smart with
anything any colors i always love going
on you know tic toc videos when people
are like painting on them and like
making designs i'm like i can do that
and
i can't do it
um but yeah i'm a bit of an air force
kind of girl as well because it also
makes me feel a bit taller because it's
got a bit of a heel on it so
anything like that i'm all for you
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah i'm always yeah but people don't
realize that until they actually stand
next to me so everyone's always like oh
you don't look that small on the pitch
then they stand next to me and make sure
that yes
i am that small like that's a good thing
because then they obviously feel like i
maybe have more of
so a presence yeah so i'm quite sure
yeah never had that growth spurt growing
up
[Laughter]
all right so obviously to be able to
make an impact on a pitch you have to
have energy you have to be able to play
for like 90 minutes plus how do you make
sure that you fuel yourself with the
right nutrition
eating eating eating yeah massive people
underestimate actually how much you
exert when you play football i think
people just think that it's like you're
running around a little bit every now
and then you'll do a sprint but as
obviously you guys know you're
constantly moving it's not just always
sprint and then you stop like you're
always doing something so for me
carbohydrates are a massive part of my
pre-match of training days
as much as i can get really you know i
don't really see
you know some people say certain amounts
or whatever but i always try and overdo
it because then i know that i've fueled
enough to keep going and i think that
was something that was massively
important in my game last season was
kind of how much i could keep going
towards the end of games and a lot of my
goals were you know 80 plus where maybe
others were getting tired and you know i
was able to keep exerting the same
energy and
obviously top-ups along the way
obviously food is one of the massive
things but top-ups you know gels
caffeine you know protein for after the
games you know for me i learned a lot
about my body
breaking down i would break down a lot
i'd have muscle injuries you know muscle
aches and things like that so taking the
protein the creatine and everything just
helped me build up that resilience a bit
more but nutrition i think is one of
them things that's taken a long time for
people to actually realize is so
important everyone talks about you know
fitness they talk about
psychology they talk about recovery
which are all massive factors but
nutrition is one that you can impact
every day you know something that you
have control over what you put in your
body sometimes you might not have access
to do an ice bath so you can't do that
as recovery you might not have access to
you know do them extra runs because your
pitch time has run out or something you
know but nutrition is something that you
can control um so yeah it was
especially these last few years has been
massive in terms of understanding when
to take things take a gel 15 minutes
before game take a protein shake at
least you know within an hour after
finishing because that's the most
important time
um so yeah i think it was
a really big influence in my season last
year
like did you always have this knowledge
or is it something that like you started
to realize later on all that recently in
your career and like yeah i guess you
spoke about how important it was i think
it's probably been in the last three to
four years that i've really started to
understand it probably more
understanding it then to understanding
my body needs it probably took a bit
longer because everybody is different
you know some people need more some
people need less for me i feel like i
need more because i want to be able to
go for 95 minutes whereas some people
maybe you know don't feel that they need
to have as much because they feel that
they they can continue to do it um so
yeah i think in the last two years i've
understood myself
more whereas my knowledge has probably
been around three to four years but
learning about yourself is really
important i guess i yeah what advice
would you give to younger girls that
maybe aren't so like comfortable
with like the idea of taking on a lot of
carbohydrates because of the impact that
you might have on their body physically
like what advice would you give them to
kind of jump over that
um hurdle
i think it's always a difficult
conversation um for myself as well
growing up you know i was always
thinking do i need to eat this like is
it an extra calorie that maybe i don't
need or you know little things like that
i think
it's always
a difficult conversation especially
within females because we're so body
conscious we always care so much about
what others think of us
and i think for me it was probably in
the last few years that i realized that
i had to
eat the right things regardless on what
impact it had on me especially you know
if i'm training every day i'm doing the
right things and you know you have to
feel right and ultimately like i'm here
to play football i'm here to play the
best ability i'm not here to you know
look good in a football kit i'm not here
to
you know
care about you know maybe that some
something looks a bit too skinny on me
or something you know like it wasn't
you know that's not that's not what i'm
here for i'm here to play football i'm
here to be an athlete and
it took a long time for me to even
realize that so you know younger girls
growing up they need to realize that
eating food is a part of life it's
normal to eat food you know you need to
do it every day life so if you're then
training on top of that you need to eat
more because you're exerting more energy
so yeah i think it's kind of getting out
that stigma of
thinking what others think of you and
thinking how you feel do you feel good
do you feel like you can play do you
feel fresh then you're doing the right
things
what do you guys eat for pre-match
nandos
good yeah pasta
[Laughter]
that used to be my thing pasta and half
time oranges
oh
cut up oranges
wedges
that's why when you used to do football
tournaments you know the moms would
bring the oranges like yeah
that was me